we're actually going to start with our
main story tonight which concerns what
happened in uvalde texas 12 days ago
when an 18 year old armed with two
ar-15s killed 19 children and two
teachers at an elementary school and
look
we all know what the key problem is here
it's guns it's because we let basically
whoever wants to buy a gun in this
country have one which has led to tragic
consequences the vast majority
of mass shooters including the shooters
at uvalde and parkland obtained the
weapons they used through legal
purchases so we know what the answer to
this problem is too
it's gun control it's meaningful
effective gun laws but that hasn't
stopped some from desperately pitching
absolutely anything other than that as a
solution the only solution is christ
jesus and being able to get some type of
spirituality and prayer back into our
schools man traps a series of
interlocking doors at the school
entrance that are triggered by a
tripwire i would like to see this a
national push
toward instead of parents buying their
kids all these tools and toys and games
invest in the classroom to make it safer
i mean they have blankets that you can
put up on the wall that are colorful and
beautiful but they're ballistic blankets
what are you talking about
use a blanket is not a strategy for
stopping deaths during a school shooting
it's barely a strategy for a bird got in
the house
and while those ideas are clearly
ridiculous hardening our schools often
comes up as an alternative to gun
control and at the nra convention that
inexplicably still took place in texas
just three days after the shooting there
wayne lapierre picked the exact same
solution that he did after sandy hook
and after parkland we also need to fully
fund our nation's police departments and
school security resource officer
programs
exactly put police or school resource
officers or sros as they're sometimes
called into schools and i guess it's not
that surprising that the solution from
the ceo of the nra is more people with
guns it'd be like hearing the garbage
dump is overflowing so we need more
piles of garbage from the head of the
national raccoon association i mean what
else do you really expect him to say
but the idea of adding police to schools
does seem to come up in the wake of
every big school shooting and crucially
it's then the thing that we always do in
fact in the six years after the
columbine massacre in 1999 the federal
government awarded over 750 million
dollars resulting in the hiring of over
6 500 sros and since then it has
exploded to the point that the most
recent data available shows 58
of american schools report having a
sworn law enforcement officer on campus
at least once a week and this has
happened even as vital resources for
students have been starved a recent
report found 14 million students go to a
school with police but without a
counsellor nurse psychologist or social
worker that is 14 million kids who are
in closer proximity to a pair of
handcuffs than they are to a medical or
mental health professional and to hear
some cops tell it there is upside to
their presence that goes far beyond
school safety that they're also there to
build trust in police from an early age
do you think every school should have a
police officer at it unfortunately yes
it's it's sad
and if you think of it morbidly
but
if you think of it building
relationships
for our future
why not it wouldn't hurt wouldn't hurt
are you absolutely sure about that
because little secret if we are showing
you something on this show it could
absolutely hurt there has never been a
moment where we've shown you a clip
where a cop goes wouldn't hurt and we've
said you're right officer big man it
wasn't anyway that's our show have a
great weekend
so so given that once again in the wake
of yet another school shooting we've
seen poised to throw more cops into our
schools we thought tonight it'd be worth
talking about school police whether they
are the answer to this particular
problem the answer to any problems or
whether they're actually a pretty big
problem themselves and let's start by
acknowledging that this idea isn't just
coming from the nra it's coming from
parents too like this man who back in
february showed up at a county council
meeting alex turner tells us he is all
in favor of the idea of adding sros
for the simple fact that they've got a
force multiplier
in the school where they could stop some
imminent threat to our children turner
has two young children and his wife
works at a school district in the county
what scares me the most is is the
thought of her having to use a backpack
to defend herself from someone with a
gun our children are are the most
important thing to our future their
future taxpayers their future citizens
that are going to invest in our
community
okay
obviously
that guy calling children future
taxpayers
is a little bit weird although who among
us has not walked into our sleeping
child's room become overtaken by the
serenity on their face and thought to
ourselves wow what a miracle
i wonder if she'll grow up to file with
a w-2 or a 1099. parenthood truly is a
joyous mystery
but i do get what he's trying to say
there the thought of someone coming into
a school and hurting your child is
incredibly scary i don't think that all
people who believe that police officers
make schools safer have bad intentions
or are arguing in bad faith but i do
believe that they are wrong because for
the record the answer to the question do
policing schools deter school shootings
is basically no experts who've studied
this have found that school shooters
were not deterred due to the presence of
metal detectors locked doors security
cameras or school resource offices and
if you think well okay but what about
when a shooting's actually happening
they could stop them then right
don't be so sure
famously both uvalde and parkland had
school police officers and things still
went the way that they did instances of
school police stopping shootings are
actually incredibly rare there was one
example four years ago but when the
washington post looked into it after
that they could only find one other case
in the preceding 19 years where a
resource officer gunned down an active
shooter it's actually much easier to
find stories of shooting stopped by
faculty and school counselors but rather
than arguing anecdotes by anecdote it
might be helpful to look at the larger
data because on the whole an analysis of
179 shootings on school grounds which is
a brutal thing to say out loud on its
own
found no evidence that the presence of
school resource officers lessened the
severity of school shootings if anything
they can actually make it worse as this
researcher explains so when we've looked
at this um and looked at school
shootings and attempted school shootings
what's remarkable is that when you have
armed officers on the scene you actually
see more casualties often because that
perpetrator is suicidal they're familiar
with that school they know that officer
is there and so they come in heavily
armed right and if school cops can make
shootings worse why then are we still
pitching them as a solution if off
discover that their mosquito repellent
attracted mosquitoes they'd stop selling
it or at the very least rebrand it as a
cologne for lonely mosquito bachelors
the point is the evidence for cops in
schools deterring school shootings just
is not there and the evidence for the
damage they can do is significant so for
the rest of this piece let's actually
put shootings aside and consider the
very real impact that school police can
have on kids every day that they are
there the national association of school
resource officers essentially the trade
group for these officers will argue that
they serve many functions in schools way
beyond security they even developed a
triad concept of school policing that
suggests an sro should simultaneously be
a teacher informal counsellor and law
enforcement officer and i will say there
are undoubtedly schools where some kids
see their police officers that way
you've probably seen videos of them
doing carpool karaoke in their squad car
with kids or doing a fun dance at their
half time show some have even joined
kids in extracurricular activities it's
not every day that you see the campus
police officer taking on the role of
cast member in the school musical she
showed up at our first rehearsal our
first dance rehearsal and i was like
why is officer griffin here is someone
in trouble
but then everyone was like no she's
joining the show she's gonna dance with
us and i was shocked
shocked because prior to her
participation most of these students
were intimidated by the officer tasked
with keeping order on campus it's true a
cop was in the school musical
and just imagine how challenging that
casting decision must have been for the
theater teacher well susie has a
fantastic vocal range hannah b really
learned the choreography jillian's a
senior so it does feel like it's her
time to get a big role but officer
griffin has a gun so
you know i guess i'm just going to go
with officer griffin
but clearly tap dancing officer griffin
here is not the norm in fact while
school police in more well-resourced
schools often do have an expanded role
including education and mentoring in
disadvantaged schools they're more
likely to engage primarily in law
enforcement activities and for all
nazareth's talk of the triad model when
they asked their members which prong
they identify with the most over
two-thirds selected law enforcement
because of course they did they're cops
most cops don't get into copying because
they secretly want to be counsellors
they do it because movies make it look
exciting and they're tired of stopping
at red lights that's why they do it
and the problem is faculty and school
administrators will sometimes use those
cops to deal with basic disciplinary
problems in the school as this teacher
explains i see that teachers have
neglected to figure out a way to handle
a lot of problems on their own that they
used to things that were up to the
teacher before are now just a phone call
away how many of your peers are just
picking up the phone and calling the
school resources i'd say the majority of
teachers are doing that
definitely 75 percent out of all of us
if i just want to make a rough
guess are doing that
because they go in with a set lesson
plan and when the kid doesn't want to do
it what do i do i get him out of the
classroom
yeah but that's not good and i know
teachers have an exhausting job and for
some reason society has decided that
their reward for that is insultingly low
pay and occasional thank you apples and
it's not the point here but why apples
exactly why we decided to reward
teachers the same way we reward mediocre
horses
because the good horses get sugar cubes
now am i saying teachers should get
sugar cubes instead of apples i'm not
not saying that
but the larger point is while i
understand a frustrated overworked
teacher wanting a troublemaking kid out
of their classroom involving the police
in that is a very dangerous impulse for
many reasons one of them is policing
schools can and do arrest students in
fact in the most recent year recorded
they did this to over 54 000 of them
which is a huge number if you ask me
what do you think happens 54 000 times
inside schools i'd say i don't know the
number of classroom pets that went
missing because a student left the lid
off the cage or the number of times a
teacher lost total control of her class
when any part of her private life was
revealed oh my god she had a computer
hooked up to the projector and an evite
from someone named jim appeared who is
jim
are you in love will you have his babies
and if you're thinking wow a kid must be
doing something really bad to get
arrested in school
not really
students have been charged with assault
for things like throwing a paper
airplane a baby carrot and skittles and
drug possession for carrying a maple
leaf and when a five-year-old with adhd
had a tantrum they were charged with
battery on a police officer when clearly
the only thing they were guilty of was
being a [ __ ] five-year-old
and take what happened with kyra wilmot
when she was a high school student she
tried to replicate the experiment that
she'd seen in class where you set off a
chemical reaction in a plastic bottle to
make the cap blow off and i'll let her
and then her mother explain what
happened next the
principal and vice principal were like
about 10 feet away
and when it popped they came over and
asked what was going on i told him it
was a science project and they were just
like okay
at the end of third period
they take me out and then walked me to
the
resource officer
he was like this is considered a felony
i might have to arrest you for this
and then i was just handcuffed and put
in the car a trained officer of the law
arrested put my daughter in handcuffed
put her in the back of a police car and
took her
to the juvenile assessment center
and charged her
with two felony charges that is so
[ __ ] stupid for so many reasons one
of which is that when you hear felony
for a science experiment you're thinking
meth if i gave you 500 guesses for what
science experiment got someone charged
with a felony your first 499 guesses
would be meth and the next one would be
are you 100 sure that it's not meh
never in your wildest dreams would it be
popping a bottle cap unless inside that
bottle was some meth
now i should say the charges against
kira were later dropped but she still
had to check the box on her college
application asking have you been
arrested
and as crazy as this sounds she was
technically lucky in that at least she
had press coverage of her ridiculous
arrest that she could direct the college
to but that is obviously not the case
for many many others
the fact is kids with criminal records
can have a much harder time getting jobs
scholarships and a host of other
benefits and opportunities and while
it's true that you can apply to have
your juvenile record sealed usually once
you turn 18 there is no guarantee that
that will happen so an arrest alone can
still do significant damage as some of
those involved in this system will admit
i think we certainly see a lot of cases
that we think seriously garnett says
close to 70 percent of the time her
probation officers decide the offense
isn't actually serious enough to get
referred to the district attorney for
criminal charges but even in those cases
much of the damage is already done the
child can still be left with a criminal
record
well will still show an arrest on their
on their um rap sheet yes absolutely
they've been arrested i mean if they
if the case comes to us they've been
arrested whether they were putting
handcuffs and brought to us or just
given a slip of paper by the police
they've been arrested and is that fair
well
i mean
no i don't think it's fair
wow that was a long pause
and it's not a great sign that a chief
probation officer is responding to the
question is the justice system fair like
they're stalling for time on jeopardy
after accidentally buzzing in
and i will say at least she is
acknowledging that that the system has a
significant problem what is absolutely
maddening is watching this former
director of student services for the
county where she works trying to make
excuses for it
no student on our that's attending our
campus is getting a criminal record
because of something we've done we don't
focus on arresting or sending kids away
that's that's completely counter to what
an educator should do but that is what's
happening
that is not happening in my school
district but in a single school year 283
kids in your district were referred to
police okay so what is happening
kids are cited on our campuses sometimes
yes and do you know that this can give
them a criminal record
i know what happens when i issue my own
consequences i don't know what happens
when police issue their consequences so
you have no idea that these kids are
getting criminal records i wouldn't know
that one way or the other
but don't you had discipline for the
district and i take care of discipline
for the district if consequences go
beyond that into the into the legal
realm that's not our purview that's not
our business
holy [ __ ] that is selective not your
business oh no my good [ __ ] that is
very much your business
and i do understand the distinction that
budget bill murray is trying to draw
there there is school discipline which
falls under his purview but if a kid
breaks the law then it's a police thing
but in practice
once you let the police into your
schools that line gets really blurry and
you're going to start getting stupid
arrests for things like science
experiments or throwing baby carrots or
in the district where that guy worked
the indefensible arrest of this autistic
student two years ago adrian was at a
school bret hart middle in san jose when
he used a small rock to etch the letters
a-d-r-x on the sidewalk the abbreviation
is how adrian often signed his name on
school assignments the letters measured
just six inches tall but the school
believed they were big enough a reason
to involve campus police
adrian was arrested at 13. i thought
maybe someone would look at it and say
oh look a legend or look at a legend
that this is so cool a legend was at
this school okay for the record that kid
was and remains a legend
because to 13 year olds there is simply
nothing cooler than initials written
somewhere it doesn't matter where or
with what all that matters is that
initials are somewhere and that is cool
on a desk yes please
on a lamppost i love it
way high up on a wall how did they get
it up there
we even put adrian's initials onto the
set behind me to make it absolutely
clear to everyone that a legend was very
much here
that story is completely bananas even
before you learn that the letters he
etched came right off with some soap and
water after his mother had him clean it
up but it also speaks to a bigger issue
which is that students with disabilities
are almost three times more likely to be
arrested even though kids with
developmental disabilities can have
difficulty understanding or following
the rules and require support staff
familiar with their specific needs and
they are not the only students
disproportionately singled out because
cops in schools do tend to behave the
same way they behave outside of schools
which explains why black students
account for nearly a third of all
students arrested despite the fact that
that is twice their share of enrollment
that is just one reason why while you
may hear a lot of white kids talk about
their friendly sro black students even
in the same school may see them very
differently it was almost like
this man was judge jury and executioner
and he was menacing looking and
literally he walked through the halls
like he owned the place
every conversation you had with him was
tense it was literally
just students of color i don't think
even the black sro that we had at
southwest i i had never seen him speak
to a white student they knew who they
were looking for they had their kids
that they like
low-key terrorized
there are so many students who
would have had a great time but had a
horrible time
because
of an sro or because of a cop
right the presence of police can make
school miserable for some kids and we
frankly don't need any more ways to make
school scarier it's already terrifying
enough if you ask me what is the
scariest place i can imagine it's not a
haunted house or the inside of tom
cruise's brain
it's high school because remember i was
this
and it's it's not just
no key
terrorizing you may be familiar with
viral videos of school cops behaving
violently videos that sometimes went on
to make awful headlines like these and
because cops in schools enjoy all the
same protections they do everywhere else
the consequences in many of these cases
can be non-existent in osceola county
florida an officer was filmed throwing a
female student to the floor knocking her
unconscious but he wasn't charged with
any wrongdoing and his supervisor the
county sheriff fully supported that
outcome a lot of things are never going
to look pretty on camera but guess what
you know this worked out
and
it's a positive thing for law
enforcement sheriff lopez defending
deputy fournier's actions despite
criticism and public scrutiny it's
unfortunate that the young lady
went through this incident
but it's also unfortunate
that my deputy had to suffer
a lot of uh constant bashing and uh
harassment
you know when he just did what how he
was trained i honestly think no one
makes a better case for defunding the
police than the police themselves if
throwing your kid to the ground and then
having your boss complain about how
everyone was rude to you afterward is
emblematic of how you were trained then
the problem is clearly the training the
cops themselves the entire system and
not for nothing that shows fake oakley
sunglasses but but the sheriff of
flavourtown here does raise
an interesting point school police get
trained as cops but that might be the
only training they get because
requirements vary widely in each state
if they exist at all and national
training requirements for school-based
law enforcement simply do not exist and
when you've got law enforcement
stationed in a school taking ordinary
disciplinary situations and escalating
them the consequences as you have seen
tonight can be truly terrible in
researching this piece we've found so
many stories where kids are still
traumatized by the experiences they had
even years later and felt they both
changed the trajectory of their lives
and how they interact with the world
if you are over a certain age this is so
much more prevalent than you might think
we don't have a particularly large staff
but multiple members of it have come
forward as we put this story together
this week citing terrible behaviour by
school police they'd either directly
witnessed or experienced first hand and
we're not even getting into the fact
that schools with sros have higher rates
of exclusionary discipline things like
suspensions and expulsions than
comparable schools without sros which
has been shown to be associated with
lower academic achievement dropout and
increase behavioral problems both in and
out of school so when that guy that you
saw earlier argued for more police in
every school saying why not it wouldn't
hurt the odds to that is it absolutely
can and it does all the time
and for all the arguing right now about
how we need more police in schools i
would argue that we may actually need
significantly less
and small reforms just are not going to
cut it here some places have tried that
with tactics that kept the police in
schools but tried to make them appear
less intimidating about five years ago
some districts in minnesota where that
kid went to school redesigned their
school police uniforms to light blue
polo shirts something that
unsurprisingly students there including
him saw right through every day i go to
school as a young black male teen and i
have to see
our sro just wandering the hallways he's
always in our classrooms he's always in
the hallways your compromise is to give
them softer outfits that doesn't make
sense
like it's
at the end of the day a cop is a cop
whether you dress them up in red yellow
blue it doesn't matter
yeah he's right teenagers aren't stupid
you can't send the cop uniform to a
farm-up state they know what is going on
a cop is going to be a cop no matter
what we dress them up in fuchsia still a
cop the million still a cop cher's dress
from the 1986 oscars still a cop and now
they're wearing something they couldn't
pull off in their wildest [ __ ] dreams
now there are some slightly bigger steps
that we can take like demanding school
districts adopt rules that keep cops out
of routine student discipline and we can
also require that they have
comprehensive training that includes
de-escalation and working with students
with disabilities or
we could just try and get them out of
schools altogether
some cities like oakland california have
done that and i am not saying it is
simple there is still a thoughtful
ongoing conversation there about how to
handle everything from routine
discipline to emergency situations
because they know
getting rid of school police doesn't
mean walking away from school safety
what it means is asking ourselves what
really keeps kids safe
and i would argue that one good way to
do that might be to take the money that
it seems we're now inevitably about to
flood towards school cops and instead
directed toward councillors nurses and
all the other resources that actually
protect students school police
are not the answer to school shootings
the answer to that is gun control and
when we throw more cops into schools as
an easy way out of that difficult and
necessary conversation
we not only fail to keep our kids safe
from gun violence we condemn them to a
system that criminalizes the very
essence of childhood kids deserve to be
annoying without being arrested to be
sad and angry without being body slammed
they deserve to have tantrums throw
carrots do science experiments talk [ __ ]
and carve their name into stuff
without risking ending up in the back of
a police car
they deserve to be curious to make
mistakes to go a little too far to be a
little too loud to basically be a
[ __ ] kid
and they definitely deserve better than
the fundamental lie that the only thing
that can stop a bad guy with a gun is a
good guy who can arrest a five-year-old
you